and i am convinced six months into this
administration the worst six months
start to any administration in my
lifetime
i'm convinced so many americans are like
well maybe
maybe maybe i didn't bargain for this
maybe this
is maybe i should have voted for
president trump you know some of these
people who
for whatever you know reason decided not
to vote for president trump who was such
a great president
and they and they vote for biden i think
they're like buyer's remorse big time
they're like
filling up their gas tank whoa this is
costing a lot more price of eggs bread
milk lumber
price of tvs price price of an airline
ticket price of a hotel everything's up
and and crime in the streets and oh oh i
know by the way
march was the highest month on record of
illegal crossings
in at our southern border until april
and april was the highest month
until may and may was the highest month
until june that's what you call a trend
in a very bad direction
so i think all that they're like saying
uh this this
is so i think that that's how it gets
through is like americans have common
sense and they're figuring it out
yeah so all right so one other thing on
big tech and then and then we'll move on
to some of the other stuff
are you worried at all this is sort of
an extension of the black pill question
but just that this stuff has become so
big that no matter what you do
no matter what you do at this point that
do you think it's possible the ship has
just sailed
and the government cannot do anything
look i'm
i'm concerned i'm nervous i mean don't
misunderstand i think
i think just you know obviously with
with the question you asked
you have that you share that same
concern but i mean i always come back to
like this is america we're americans we
get things done we've solved problems
we've tackled all kinds of obstacles i
mean
you know there's a there's a there's
some people who make the case that you
know it's just
um this this tough rugged attitude is in
our dna you know you think about the
people who started this place
over in europe they said you got to
practice your faith a certain way and
they said no we don't
we'll get on the ship we'll risk it all
we'll go to this place called america
and we're going to do it the way we
think
we need to do it and the way the good
lord wants us to do it and they did it
and we've overcome everything and become
the greatest country ever so
i still feel like there's a ton of
people who think like you and i do
who think like the folks i get to
represent back in the fourth district of
ohio
who are willing to say no we're not
going to let it happen we're going to
fight we're going to do what it takes
in the right way to to to prevail in the
end
for freedom for liberty for free speech
um
so i i guess i'm optimistic and maybe
maybe it's just because i'm
you know like you i'm american and i i
love the way we
we conquer things and get things done
well i always tell people i'm a world
weary optimist because i'm an optimist i
don't think i could do this if i wasn't
how could you say what you think for a
living if you were an optimist but but
i'm also a realist so that that gives
you a little world weary
but to that point though if there if
there are enough of us or let's say
there's more of us than them
what do we do about some of this
election stuff because it seems to me i
i played a clip on the show last week
which was a compilation
of of democrats in 2018 including
kamala and klobuchar you probably saw it
oh yeah it's about 15 democrats talking
about
rigged elections talking about voting
machines that don't work talking about
hacking all of the stuff
that i'm pretty sure you and i could get
blown up here on youtube right this very
moment
for talking about if we talk about it
now right right because dave
you forgot only democrats are allowed to
object to election results
we cannot always i have to make it out
of you yeah we're not allowed to
i mean yeah uh you think about the folks
on this this uh
january 6 commission on the democrat
side benny thompson objected to the
election results in 2001 when president
bush won
uh jamie raskin the lead impeachment
managers in impeachment round two
uh he objected to florida on january 6
2017.
uh jim mcgovern jim mcgovern on the day
we had this
the second impeachment uh debate on the
floor on january 13th
he brought up the the week before
january 6 and he said republicans
objected to the will of people last week
when they
tried to overturn the will of people and
they objected so i got up to speak right
after that and i said well
you know i said that i i said the the
fine gentleman the chairman of the rules
committee from massachusetts mr mcgovern
said that we
we try to overturn the will of people i
said but guess who was the first person
to object on january 6 2017.
guess he was the first person it was the
right fine gentleman from massachusetts
who objected to
alabama think about that dave alabama
president trump won by like 28 points
he so he can object to alabama but jim
jordan and republicans can't object to
pennsylvania where they
unconstitutionally change their election
law i mean think about this one fact
the election law and passed by the uh by
the legislature as the constitution
requires
in pennsylvania said election ends at
eight o'clock tuesday you know
of course election day is always on
tuesday first tuesday after the first
monday in november
into eight o'clock tuesday democrats
sued in the partisan state supreme court
and the partisan state supreme court
controlled by democrats says no
we don't care what the what the
legislature said we don't care what the
law says
election day now ends at five o'clock
friday they just extend the election
for three days so i'm not allowed to
object to that but jim mcgovern can
object to alabama when donald trump wins
alabama by 28 points
you got to be kidding me so that that's
the part that it drives
and it's my guess is you spend a lot of
your time doing the same thing i do
pointing out the freaking double
standard with these people but you have
to do it because
if not they'll get away with it more
let's not forget i think his name is
josh shapiro the secretary of state of
pennsylvania who announced two days
before the election that biden was going
to win pennsylvania
before the election yeah the guy
counting the votes
announces two days before who's going to
win
maybe there's a problem with them do you
need to call me craig maybe
maybe you know but of course democrats
like oh you guys are crazy you're
somehow we're the conspiracy theorists
for just like just like raising a
question about that so
so what do you guys do on messaging then
because i'm not kidding i went through
the nine bullet points in the last texas
bill you know on the election that the
hb3 that they were going crazy over
and it really it was things like id it
was uh
paper trail it was having cameras when
you're counting and a couple
very very basic things there was nothing
about race in there there was nothing
right to stop anyone from voting there
were actually things like actually
extending benefits so employers
could give more time for people to vote
and yet it's called racist it's repeated
in
associated press and on nbc and
everything else like how do
you beat that narrative you know i think
well again you point out the facts you
do like like like you did but i also
think like
i'm past that point what else do you do
besides that i i think i think americans
get it so take this take the
the the the texas democrats so first of
all that america sees texas democrats
getting on a private plane uh you know
taking their football and going home
not doing their job coming to you know
this this is emblematic of what the
democrats think
i'm gonna not do my job and i'm going to
go to washington where i can say i'm a
victim i mean
that is like so democrat right so they
come to washington they spread covet
around to everybody else they found a
plane with no mass they
they had they probably had to show so i
think sometimes just the common sense of
americans like
these people are crazy and i am
convinced six months into this
administration the worst six months
start to any administration in my
lifetime
i'm convinced so many americans are like
well maybe
maybe maybe i didn't bargain for this
maybe this
is maybe i should have voted for
president trump you know some of these
people who
for whatever you know reason decided not
to vote for president trump who was such
a great president
and they and they vote for biden i think
they're like buyer's remorse big time
they're like
filling up their gas tank whoa this is
costing a lot more price of eggs bread
milk lumber
price of tvs price price of an airline
ticket price of a hotel everything's up
and and crime in the streets and oh oh i
know by the way
march was the highest month on record of
illegal crossings
in at our southern border until april
and april was the highest month
until may and may was the highest month
until june that's what you call a trend
in a very bad direction
so i think all that they're like saying
uh this this is
so i think that that's how it gets
through is like americans have common
sense and they're figuring it out
congressman just to be clear they're not
kids in cages anymore they're
they're young people in fun centers yeah
exactly
i've been down here well since i can
since i can tell you're not holding back
today you just mentioned uh biden i mean
what what do you think is really going
on with biden uh
he is not all there that's my
professional uh
diagnosis well you know look
you know it's it's in some ways it's a
it's a big concern because as much as we
talk about all the issues we've talked
about
in the end you know our adversaries see
the same thing that
that we see and you know you saw oh this
is probably
three months ago uh when our secretary
of state secretary blinken was in alaska
in anchorage
meeting with his chinese counterpart and
you know we had our team on one side of
the table and they had the chinese on
the other side
and the treatment that the chinese gave
to
the secretary of state of the united
states of america
i'm like i mean it was it was
embarrassing and
and then and frankly you didn't see
secretary blinken really push back
it's like if that happened well first of
all that would not happen in the trump
administration to mike pompeo but if it
did
if they were crazy enough to say those
kind of things to pompeo i know
i know mike he'd got up like maybe he'd
flip the table over or he would he would
have got up or he would have said
with all due respect that is entirely
wrong you don't talk to i mean
it would have there would have been
pushback real pushback like you're
supposed to do in real diplomacy when
you come from a position of strength
and it didn't happen and i'm like now we
see china what they said to japan just a
couple days ago
and now we see what putin is saying
about any type of things we're going to
put in europe
i'm like that's what happens when you
don't project strength
and when you have a commander-in-chief
you have a president united states who
is
behaving in the way president biden is
and it's in its
dangerous for not only the united states
and our security but frankly for our
allies and
and how things work in the world and
that's
that's troubling i think and yeah i mean
obviously you see it and i think so many
americans do
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the
notification bell